we never expected to have freedom or
independence or equality in this country
but it doesn't matter what the
challenges are you run through that wall
[Music]
whether you know it or not right here
right now
you are a coming of age story
mr alfred welcome to ap english i prefer
my stripper name
[Music]
boogie
no one believes in an asian basketball
player have mercy on muscle
it's a joke in this country we can cook
clean count real good but anything else
we pick last
but if you stick to our plans and we
beat monk we'll get our shot at the nba
look have mercy
yo who is that oh that's eleanor
he could get it if he stops staring have
mercy on me
as a self-hate in china man i was
skeptical about boogie
i see you daddy
soup come on back in the locker room all
right all right
i'm sorry coach hawkins and principal
kodak not necessary
this is our culture alfred has parents
who value respect
and discipline and without them we are
nothing
you don't want to know what's going on
in my house my mom she's responsible but
she doesn't believe in me
my dad is irresponsible but he believes
in you
don't let me grow up
i got 5 000 years of chinese history
it's a lot of pressure
i know how you feel but you have a
chance to change history
i need you to fight for yourself the
same way you fight for being chinese
[Music]
yes this has always been about you
you're playing a beat monk so what are
you gonna
you can do up if you want